to entertainment thrills this time we're
headed for Columbia's radio Playhouse oh
it's okay mr. doorman we've special
permission to watch a rehearsal of
that popular Wednesday night radio feature
laugh with Ken Murray we're just in time to
hear the famous singing star bill regan go over
his number with Russ Morgan and his orchestra
or will you never set me free
that must be flawless and time
to the second cigarette there the lipstick traces
and their line thicker romantic places
that's way they it's foolish thing my
and now the star of the show Ken Murray
runs over some of his lines with that
clever comedian Eve Arden I got back late at
night and I couldn't get into my apartment
imagine I had a sleep in the park Oh old
home we all kidding aside E the time has
come for a final decision what would you say
if I asked you to marry me nothing I can't
talk and laugh at the same time while the
orchestra takes a rest Ken rehearses with
his famous stooge AHS blade are you doctor hurt
well if you're a dentist what's the idea dressing
like a soldier because I'm getting ready to
drill well you know doctor all of a sudden
my teeth stop hurting yeah I put it into
that yeah open your mouth oh yeah yeah why
what's the matter this is ice or
fallen arches go nurse hey me not
fishing rod you know the one with the
big hole a fishing rod with a big hook
you're not gonna put any fishing
rod with a big hook in my mouth
it says what's the big idea well when you open
your mouth so wide before yeah you know I lost
my hand and here's Russ Morgan with his morning
trombone putting his boys through their paces